the Czech Republic is the first European
country to already put in place a
strategy to end confinement on the 7th
of April 20 26 it --is UNS were once
again able to do such things as playing
football in parks or even make some
short trips within the country
[Music]
there's still a long way until the end
of the coronavirus crisis that in this
country they have achieved the first
major goal flattening the curve during
this month of April the Czech Republic
will make a transition from what is so
far being a total quarantine to what
they call smart quarantine
that's how have they achieved this
success what's with the smart quarantine
and what lessons can other countries
learn from it well in this video we're
gonna tell you
[Applause]
[Music]
the Czech Republic is a country that
hardly gets mentioned in the media
[Music]
but there are things that make this
country deserve video on visual politic
and yes we're specifically talking about
its fight against the corona virus
pandemic to give you an idea at the time
of making this video the Czech Republic
has 6,000 confirmed cases and about a
hundred and forty deaths this is one of
the few countries that can really say
it's flattens the curve all this
explains why it is also the first
country in Europe to embark on an exit
strategy from quarantine
other countries such as Austria and
Denmark are also implementing similar
plans the Czechs were the first but not
only that on the economic science this
country also has a lot boast about at
the moment unemployment as only risen to
5%
that's right despite a month of
quarantine the Czech Republic only has a
5% unemployment rate as you can see if
we compare the Czech Republic with other
countries like Italy or Spain the
difference is like night and day
so what have they done so well in this
country and I'm sure something you might
be thinking that the Czech Republic must
be spending a fortune on health care but
the truth is then not take a look at
this graph
[Music]
here you can see health spending
relative to GDP again both Spain in
Italy spend more on health care than the
Czech Republic and no checks aren't
millionaires in terms of GDP per capita
both Spaniards and Italians are richer
and at this point you might imagine that
we're going to speak highly of the Czech
government right their prime minister
must be an absolute genius across
between Churchill now Sam and Ella and
Elon Musk
well nothing of the sort look at this
[Music]
corruption cases pile pressure on Czech
Prime Minister you heard that correctly
The News says corruption cases in plural
the truth is that the Czech Prime
Minister Andrey babish is something like
a bohemian Berlusconi
a billionaire owner of various media
outlets and up to his neck in corruption
cases and I know this because I happen
to live in Prague and I have done for
several years I mean everything I'm
gonna tell you today I've lived it
firsthand so the question we are asking
ourselves today is how is it possible
that the Czech Republic is starting to
return to normal what have they done
right so I'll put it another way what of
all the other countries done so wrong
and what's smart quarantine well today
we're gonna answer all of these
questions but before we do let's take a
look at the history
best of both worlds before we talk about
coronavirus we need to talk about public
health and yes I know it's a debate that
raises passions if you're watching this
video from the United States you'll
probably have all kinds of opinions
about it some politicians say they want
european-style health care others say
that it's communism on the other side of
the pons in Europe we also have a lot of
debates about public health and many
think that there are only two health
models public or private status we
either guarantee that everyone has
access to health care or people pay if
they're able to however as we always say
on visual politic the Devils in the
details
true all European countries guarantee
universal access to health care however
each country has totally different
systems and we can talk about two great
models a beverage system and the Bismark
system
[Music]
the beverage system is what we have in
countries like Spain or the United
Kingdom under this model the state takes
care of absolutely everything and of
course private health insurance is
available as well but most citizens use
public health care and this healthcare
is controlled by the administration
whether regional or central that is
doctors are public employees and the
government is the one who decides how
many hospitals are built and where for
example let's say that I have a stomach
problem what if I lived in the UK I
would have to go to the health care
centre I've been assigned to from there
I would make an appointment with my GP
who has also been assigned to me by the
state and you're probably wondering does
this system actually work well the
answer is yes the UK in Spain and
Denmark have quality hospitals however
this system does have two problems
firstly it typically has very long
waiting lists the second thing is that
you're not free to choose your own
doctor if you're watching this video
from Spain or the UK you're probably
thinking well this is the price to pay
for universal health coverage right well
the truth is no there's actually another
system a system that in fact is the most
common one in Europe we're talking about
the Bismark system
[Music]
the Bismarck system is what they have in
countries such as Germany or the Czech
Republic in these countries there's also
public health care but it's not managed
by the state so well who manages
healthcare well there's the
responsibility of insurance agencies for
example let's go back to my stomach
problem in this case I would no longer
go to a health center that I was
assigned to but I would go to a hospital
of my choosing in many cases it doesn't
even have to be a hospital I could just
go to a private clinic the case of the
Czech Republic I know well because I
live here in Prague for example it's
very normal to go to small clinics where
there are one or two doctors who
specialize in a specific field the first
thing they're going to ask me when I go
to their clinic is for my insurance card
the insurance company is the one who's
going to pay for my treatments in the
case of the Czech Republic you can
choose from seven public insurers and
yes I did put those two words together
public insurers because even if
healthcare is not managed by the state
insurance agencies are not completely
private they are a hybrid between
nonprofit foundations and state-owned
enterprises
that is they compete with each other
they are independent but at the same
time they have regulated prices in other
words the Bismarck system has the best
of both worlds the state guarantees
universal coverage and at the same time
there's a competitive market insurers
competes to offer more coverage while
hospitals compete with each other to
obtain patients in my case for example
thanks to this system it's very easy to
find doctors who speak English without
having to pay a fortune to a private
clinic and I know what you're wondering
right now what does all of this have to
do with coronavirus
[Music]
I'll think about in a system where
everything is managed by the state
hospitals have a little autonomy so what
happened in Spain well the government
didn't take the threat of coronavirus
seriously and that means almost no
hospital goodbye masks or respirators at
the end of the day it's the government
that buys them in a Bismarck system
country's hospitals and clinics have
been able to search for health care
providers since January but hold on a
moment because this is not the only
difference let's take a look at that
other difference right now
from Taiwan with love if you have a
visit Prague there's something that's
sure to catch your eye you're gonna
encounter some tibetan flags and you'll
say well what is Tibet have to do with
Czech Republic well the truth is that
since 2018 Prague has an individual
appointed as mayor who happens to be the
man hated the most by the Chinese regime
and I'm not joking misters Danya crib is
one of the pirate parties few European
politicians who makes no secret of
showing his ill will towards Beijing
he's done so for years and in a country
like the Czech Republic this can be a
bit of a problem progress of 600,000
Chinese tourists a year and we're not
just talking about tourism for example
home credit is one of the most popular
consumer credit companies in China it's
found a patter calneh is the richest man
in the Czech Republic for years China
has made a lot of investments in this
country and home credit is just one
example at some points China came to
consider the Czech Republic as its
gateway to doing business in Europe that
honeymoon has come to an end and if
relations with China went sour on
February the 9th they were well and
truly over it's official Czech
government bans direct flights to China
it's not hard to imagine the reason for
banning flights coronavirus but as
obvious as that sounds to us now at the
time it was very controversial in fact
the Czech Republic was the only European
country to ban flights to China until
the w-h-o itself advised it check out
some of the w-h-o statements from
February 2020
w-h-o chief says widespread travel bans
not needed to beat China virus and
you'll say why did the Czech government
not listen to the advice of the WHI well
because of this
aughh mayor thanks taiwan for sharing
kovat 19 response materials exactly
throughout this year taiwan has been
sharing information with the Czech
Republic basically by breaking its ties
with Beijing Prague has teamed up with
Taipei the capital of Taiwan and these
diplomatic relations have been very
useful in the current global crisis on
the 7th of March Prague received all the
information that had been collated by
Taiwan on how to respond to the
coronavirus crisis for example contrary
to the wh o--'s recommendation taiwan
advised citizens to wear masks it also
explained how to do math tests
effectively if you think about it from a
political point of view we can
understand a pandemic as a problem of
supply and demand
suddenly demand for medical care soars
to saturate supply so what's the first
step well that's to try and reduce
demand that's why this piece of news was
so important due to the spread of the
corona virus the government declared a
state of emergency and on March 12th
2020 further tightened preventative
measures at the time the Czech Republic
only had 116 confirmed cases of kovat 19
to give you a comparison Spain did not
decree a state of alarm until 5,000
infections have been confirmed thanks to
early action check quarantine has been
much smoother for example the Czechs
were able to take small walks as long as
they wore a mask in most cases the masks
were very simple or even homemade
they've even been allowed to go out onto
the street with its scarves the goal is
not to avoid catching it but to avoid
spreading it of course covering your
mouth and nose doesn't guarantee that
you won't get it but it is true that it
is a barrier against the virus and it
reduces the chance of infection and
again the goal is not to stop infection
but to reduce it and in this regard
every measure counts
but most importantly having started
confinement measures early at the number
of infections have not escalated as fast
look at this graph
[Music]
here you can see the curve of infected
people from Spain compared to that of
the Czech Republic this is how the Czech
Republic has managed to reduce the
demand hospital beds but what about the
supply it is essential to expand it get
on with supplying masks respirators and
all equipment to protect health workers
this is why the government set out like
crazy to look for suppliers in China and
just as has happened in other countries
such as Spain the Czech Republic has
also been the victim of more than one
scam
80% of rapid kovat 19 tests that the
Czech Republic bought from China are
faulty
however this has not been the only
measure at all times the Czech Republic
has counted on its own Society for
example the Czech Institute of computer
science has developed its own respirator
designed for 3d printing even the Czech
government itself has been helping
Internet users so that they can print
their own respirators and this is a very
curious thing because as a comparison in
Spain there are also people with 3d
printers they've also been organized
online the problem well for some reason
we just don't understand the government
has rejected them Madrid says no to the
3d printer solidarity after some days
accepting homemade protecting screens
the regional government of Madrid has
changed its mind without giving any
reasons thanks to all these measures the
Czech Republic has not only prevented
saturation in hospitals it is now also
starting to help other countries
[Music]
Republic will treat six covert 19
patients from France at a university
hospital to help alleviate pressure on
the French medical system by the way
this case of solidarity between European
countries is not unique Germany and
Luxembourg are also treating French
patients and we're probably going to see
a lot of such cases as more countries
managed to curb the pandemic within
their own borders but the question that
you'll be asking yourself is so what's
the next step are all restrictions going
to be lifted is the quarantine over and
the answer's no at any moments a second
outbreak could come and all that has
been achieved would be lost so the
strategy that the Czech Republic is
testing and that will probably end up
being copied by other countries is what
they call smart quarantine public to
launch a smart quarantine data for
mobile operators and bank card payments
will now be accessible to the regional
hygiene Authority to track movements of
new coronavirus infected people in order
to identify and isolate them and it only
requires citizens to agree and give
their consent to being tracked basically
the government still contests the whole
population so what they're going to do
is use mobile phone data and credit
cards let's imagine that I take a covert
19 test and end up positive in this case
the doctors are going to ask me if I
want to give the government access to my
cell phone
of course it's all voluntary using
geolocation and my mobile data the
government can identify all the people
I've been with in the last week it's
very likely unknowingly that I could
have infected them so I and all the
potential victims would be obliged
quarantine in this way only those who
are infected have to stay at home the
rest can continue eight more or less
normal
[Music]
of course all this has a very big risk
because it requires citizens to entrust
all their private details to the
government so now the question goes over
to you would you be willing to have the
government to record your movements in
exchange for avoiding mass confinement
do you think your country will end up
doing smart quarantine - and what do you
think of it leave your answers please in
the comments below and I really do hope
you enjoyed this video if you did please
do hit that like button don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
check out our friends at the Ricans at a
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode but we're not mine and
as always thank you for watching if you
want to learn more about politics and
world affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsider podcast where we don't do the
thinking for you find reconsider at WWE
consider mediacom or on Apple or Google
Play or your favorite podcast
[Music]
[Applause]